it's
[Music]
there to
the
art so um the first thing to remember is
the art is
concentric and throughout the centuries
a good way of understanding that is is
the uh so Above So Below So within so
without okay so if I have non-c
contestation
internally you're not supposed to have
externally um no matter how much I so
for
example um I might use a cultivation
drill where he's pressing and he's
pushing okay with spinal displacement
and then I internalize that and that is
a way of developing that internally I'm
not contesting but externally this is a
contestation you see so hence the art
will move things so same thing
internally I'm doing the same uh yield
so for ex or the same internal non-c
contestation so for example if he comes
out and he now pushes on that
angle it's not going anywhere do you see
I don't I
don't I think people make a mistake is
that they take that internal cultivation
field and then violated at the external
level this is not concentric thought
okay so just because I move into an
external yield it doesn't mean that I'm
not doing the same exact thing okay I am
doing the same exact thing internally
I'm just now concentrically consistent
throughout my movement okay so you
have you have a um uh
internal internalization so internally
I'm not contesting and you can do all of
this you see on an external
contestation okay so all I'm doing here
is you're you're pushing at me and then
I remain internal and and I can just go
through you you see but that's not the
art okay because I'm just pushing
externally on this line okay so I have
to go around this
point you
see and any point in the turn any point
in the turn so let's say we're here and
he comes
out it's the
same
okay there you go
comes
out it's the
same and any angle so for
example here's this part come out sit
up you
see so as you guys are getting able to
internalize their energy all you're
doing with it now though is trying to be
more powerful you see so and so you're
like oh I'm going to put the qua into
that and you're very powerful now but
it's not the art okay so I still use the
qua but I'm going around eny you see and
it's extremely soft right okay and so
same thing here you can go here and drop
the chi do you
see but I I as I am
not contesting so same thing see feel
that contesting angle so I go this way
you see okay well and then same thing
here you're like there oh I got you
because I can qua the hell out of you do
you see but look
all so if I could sum up this
point
historically it's an concentric
epistemology what you're doing on the
inside you have to to do on the outside
you yes we do train for the inside
isolated from the outside but that's a
cultivation
field hence why when we go more live you
have to do both or you're do you
get that you can't you can't do those
straight angles and like that okay
so if you're
trying to uh get
the um the spiritual aspect
okay you could be fine here on the
inside but when you when you come back
and you go I'm going to qua the out
of you you lost the spiritual aspect and
the mind does not drop okay which is
which is somewhat different from I was
internalizing your young aspect it's not
it's not quite the same okay okay
remember it's a kind of inverse
cultivation
model I cannot have the Mind
drop when I am not internalizing your
young aspect however internalizing the
Yang aspect does not automatically
guarantee that my mind drops okay and
when you when you're using the internal
for just power over the guy your mind
won't drop okay so I use both internal
external to do the whole thing okay so
let's go back to the Z to the Zen you
you start your Zen with the tissue
dropping okay so the same thing as I do
this my
skeletal system is giving me the
feedback that I can feel my tissue
dropping okay you're giving me the
feedback by allowing me to follow that
in
space okay so meaning the way your grip
is telling me don't go here okay my
skeleton system is telling me let the
rest fall in contrast to that so you are
my contrast that's giving me my model to
work
so if you come over Virginia
and you could be at this angle and you
just you can do whatever okay and know I
won't you you can push at whatever angle
okay and it won't
change what I'm
doing it doesn't
matter
okay um
so at where you guys are
at when you when you you're going to
feel that cuz they're per prescription
spinally
displacing uh you have to get off of
that
line
okay you have to get off that line no
not here and
then you can get off of it any number of
ways if you watch that video I got off
it any number of ways cuz he he comes in
a little different every time
okay reconcile yes internally you're
going to feel the young aspect that
you're internally reconciling but you go
around that
energy okay you're going to feel it
you're going to feel it go around the
energy okay and why I had you pushing is
to show that even though it's very soft
and doesn't have the contention model
that makes me feel powerful you can't do
anything to me just like if I stopped at
any point you can't push that arm in do
do you see that so yes it's it is
soft but what it really is is non-c
contesting do you see it's not if you
push if you push past that you would
feel right everything that you're trying
to
do which is integrity of your
organization I have integrity in my
organization but it never enters into
contest with you okay
okay if you
have a young
aspect going this way we don't want to
go that way okay
you're going to at a
minimum hit it at the 90 and so this is
what I
call um your 90° fluctuation cuz nothing
ever really stays like I mean it can but
we're not going to stay in this two
Dimension right so for example uh we're
always either SP rotating or counter
spir rotating okay so th this thing is
always going like that going like this
okay it's not going to do
that so it'll be on a spiral which means
you're your 90° fluctuation is something
that's constant to that
spiral okay so for example if you have
one an a
a consistent so non uh fluctuating 90°
angle because you're on a spiral sooner
or later you're going to now violate the
rule so it's basically you did it here
you have a y Yong Clash there okay so
I'll show you what I
mean in this technique I'll use you
Maya and you're having the same thing on
certain okay so we'll just get to the
end this part here okay
so at at a certain point if you look at
her
head it is on a curve you see as it goes
down and you start that curve
okay but if your
angle is this
at a certain point it is no different
than if you're pushing her that way okay
so she's got a resistance to the throat
you see and you're trying to shove her
that way what you have to do
is here's her contention angle is just
has to keep going around her
head you feel that so we're just we'll
get there
don't go here that's what strong to
you you're going around her
head so watch how I'm doing that now I'm
going to bring her in not shove here I
going around her
head you guys see that so when you stand
up and you go here you to be careful cuz
you're going to smell it you see you're
going to push but you have to get around
her
head which is why my arm goes this way
and not this way and not that way it
keeps going around her head okay it's no
different
inag you're going to smell it but no
there is inertia to her standing as you
keep going around her head around her
head
okay there's no different so you have to
keep that 90° fluctuation you're doing
it at the beginning
too uh if I push
here at this point we're contesting no
different than here so I keep going
here's that contention point and I keep
going around it you
see then here's a contention point and I
keep going around it and around
it okay
and that is a simple kind of
mathematical way of understanding the
external non-c
contestation constantly 90° fluctuation
hitting it from the side not against it
okay
try here here's that 180 so I have to
get off of it I go to that
90 okay here it is again so I go around
it you see there it is again I go around
it again you see okay then it's coming
back it's right here I go to the inside
of it okay here it is again don't shove
it
down I got to go this way to have the
angle if I go this way I'll never get it
I have to go this
way here it is he's pushing so you can
see oh get off of it on the
90 here it is again go around it there
it is again go around it more okay here
it is again go on the inside go around
it there it is right there don't take it
go around it
[Music]
okay let's go yeah it
doesn't okay
stay who
right because there's an internal right
so what you have is like modern iido
will just do the external do you see but
without the internal I can't get to the
spiritual component so remember how I
was having you push on you you're
pushing on me don't push on me just be
your arm should have the Integrity
you're pushing on me you're pushing on
me you see that it's external bracing
angle you get it okay it's got to be
tension
free so here here I am tension free you
see and you push on me push on you push
on
me you see okay got it so again
boom you get it so you can't just do you
can't just get out of the way it's both
is it we we came from the internal to
the external but now you guys are all
external and not the internal you have
to have the internal okay switch
roles and see you can
stop whoa okay it's got to
[Music]
be internal not external only that's why
it's concentric it's not one or the
other it has to be both the people that
are just internal are wrong and the
people who are just external are wrong
okay okay it has to be both you can give
me this hand and I should be able to
check that angle okay guys got it okay
so right now what H why does that happen
because you're just doing the throw cuz
you're good ayoka and you go k hole
don't do that just do the exercise do
the exercise do you understand it just
happens to be C you hole but you're
doing the exercise as your teachers
prescribed you're not doing coo as a
federation
okay try it
again I
won't um we'll get to there okay Bo at
some point you're going to so here's
that go back to where we were okay so
here is your Yong contention point so I
go around it you see and now if I keep
pushing it do you feel that no don't
push it KY ho transfers from the grip to
the upper arm you see okay now if I move
my elbow that way that's against your
standing inertia that's a Yong Yong
Clash you see that's what everyone does
okay so we get to where we are and we'll
just work from here now okay so what I'm
going to do is still follow the yin
space so you can take that out out it's
here in front of
you and it's here between your legs you
see
that I don't want to
step in a
way that the elbow pressure increases at
the contention
Point okay so you could keep your elbow
still not feel like you're doing your
arm but if this foot steps away it's
brought elbow pressure so you just
thread the yin
space this way okay now no elbow right
no elbow pressure okay now watch what
happens you see your base is is already
falling and then the weight of the arm
finds the outside of your
head
okay it's not
Me Knocking you over it's me trying not
to contest not
contest
[Music]
okay you see that okay so I want you to
train it that way forget the throw cuz
the throw is making you push elbow
pressure against that 180 okay so again
you can think of it I'll give you the
phrase thread the needle thread the
needle thread the needle
okay right